hello and welcome to this video playing
FM GM gatas hmmm something from Brazil
okay so and yeah let's play some some
funky sideline him when who was Sicilian
at least we got the open saw you ok so
we should be seven he just plays g3 no
matter what it seems good aha
interesting maybe you can do something
funny here ok so age three mmm it's
possible maybe to play with Bishop to d7
here's some how to prevent him from
castling Italy's Got neither forged ok
that's not totally ideal ok
yeah I might have hmm take you on d5
impossible night before what sir um
possibility him so what to do he ever
cheek 95 maybe I guess that looks kind
of normal he still has this castling
issue hmm ok looks very weaker the c3
pawn but maybe there is no way to
exploit it
let's do this threatening 93 m or
potentially Bishop b3 is still cannot
castle and there's no night move here
okay he did cancel so so I'll just take
this right where's the point maybe you
was just sick of defending this this
idea um ok so here I can check on k
close down taking first is good and now
is there some f5 maybe anyway this is
the right right move there's no use in
going back in some way ok so we maybe
even age for here why not let's open up
age 3 or queen c5 is also strong for
Queen here ass queen of three though ok
let's establish this pawn it's not bad
and now Queen c5 yeah burdening made
this is the only move I think and now no
I can do a tough loss thanks Knight f6
is some is winning the d5 pawn I can
also go f5
let's do this
yeah I like you fine or is their big
idea i don't see it and it's crap okay
so he wants to take b7 hmm ok yeah I
don't have a fantastic square I am
that's true okay let's go back okay if I
castle i can take age 3 youjizz not so
great
you cannot take h3 because of Queen f5
ok just a double attack ok see ready for
Bishop e3 I guess he is how to do this
now I'm still I let's start with the
move I mean it's not so easy to even
cover the rook and I can move the night
with the tempo with a very strong tempo
actually where is he going with this PM
soulknight you for now or yeah it's
let's go there
very strange solo q 5 coming a cat's
keep this for the moment OOP the eighth
and d5 and I have to keep an eye on the
clock
I haven't really paid attention there
that much and now i'm pretty much behind
yeah that wasn't good here okay I'm
threatening at least drooped xe5 now if
you take syd Queen Queen back I couldn't
be one I mean what would win so Roxy
five is a threat it's not even not easy
to cover that even this one now karacan
okay let's let's do this after and speed
up a little bit here maybe that's not
the strongest very likely it's not the
strongest but a quick solution is also
not bad here time morning each point is
so pretty strong and he cannot really do
much it's very limited to him
I could have taken a for it would have
been better actually but okay some quick
moves also help the strength of this H
porn is just absolutely enormous
okay three maybe what's better I don't
know I just want to keep it simple maybe
this wasn't a good move actually it
wasn't check oh I actually didn't see
that what it was hanging not good check
hmm so Frankie position how do i
actually have to have to prevent the the
steel media in the first place here you
will take I it's again a stalemate I'm
stupid teen stupid stuff check check
game drawn ah ok bad bad technical
player ok I got myself into some trouble
you with the time but now I'm actually
it's equal and I should really win this
quite easily yeah okay this is Sir I can
I have two words of fled win here yet
and of course of course you should win
you have it it's it's not so easy now
with no time you have to avoid all the
shouldered stalemates um yeah how to do
it night night here here here yeah it's
the thing yeah yeah now it ok it's it's
just a matter of making this in the
right time yeah here here we have the
draw but I had to add no time on the
clock yeah probably here I have to bring
the Rucker and have to bring this over
again like to F for new talent Winnie
actually you can always do this
yeah this is unfortunately a draw draw
unfortunately very weird okay let's say
I have a brief look at this game the
game that I certainly should have won
after he just yeah gave away aged three
without any particular point yep Jan
yeah it was a bit too relaxed with the
clock i think i only saw here like oh
I'm clearly behind on time when the
position is winning but you tend to get
nervous and yeah this is a fairly easy
technical winner and summer maybe I
should have tried to avoid yeah here
book a three for example it's a lot
stronger I shouldn't trade routes yeah
this is Sam just not a good technical
way of playing this because his rook is
really bad but I tend to get nervous
when I'm lower on targets but by know it
was kind of okay I tend to simplify or
just trade too much um yeah okay one is
just a bad trait he has no counter play
anyway and his rookie is very passive
just needing to defend something like
this is a pretty easy win yeah I just
bring the cab now the way it went yeah
it's got tricky because of those weird
um those via draw I have this snare this
is really bad i should have taken a bit
of time I wasn't total Blitzen blitz
mode still thinking I'm down on time but
by now I'd equalize the night of to us
when it's not really difficult
ok anyway I hope you enjoyed the game
thanks for watching